foreign
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City the headline rate of
inflation in the UK fell last month but
it remained stubbornly in double digits
Consumer Price inflation fell from 10.4
percent in February to 10.1 percent last
month that was higher than the 9.85
figure that the market had been
expecting the office for National
statistics said downward pressure was
exerted on the headline figure by lower
petrol and diesel prices
but offsetting that will hire food and
drink prices those were up by 19.1
percent last month on a year-on-year
basis that was up from 18.2 percent in
February and was the fastest rate since
August 1977. the ons said that the price
of bread and cereals increased by the
fastest on record
this is a small headline full but it
disguises a large rise in food inflation
which is causing pressure to families up
and down the country as they see their
cost of their weekly food shop go up
and it shows that there is no such thing
as an automatic fall in the headline
rate of inflation that's why we have a
plan and if we're going to reduce that
pressure on families it's absolutely
essential that we stick to that plan and
we see it through so that we halve
inflation this year as the Prime
Minister has promised
well joining me now is Yale selfish he's
Chief Economist at KPMG yeah good to see
you this morning up inflation is proving
much much stickier than expected in the
UK
yes it is brewing a little bit stickier
in the UK and it would be due to your
range of issues that we have here
particularly
um and it is unfortunate because it is
making the bank of England
um job a little bit trickier
why do you think the UK does have this
problem with persistent inflation more
than other countries in Western Europe
well
it's partially difficult to say but it
could be partially because
um of the issues that we have with trade
so so Imports are potentially a little
bit more expensive now than the where we
also have shortages in in of Labor in
certain sectors that make the cost of
producing certain things in the UK in
the UK more expensive
so could the fact that the pound has
started to tick higher in recent days
come to the to the rescue at all here
that should help a little bit but um I
think we'll need a bit more than that
no we don't talk much about retail price
inflation RPI it's a bit of a
discredited uh measure of inflation
these days but I mean it's worth
pointing out that is still pretty uh
elevated at 13 and a half percent that's
crucial of course because a lot of the
UK's national debt about 28 of it the
interest payments are linked to RPI
yes indeed so I mean it is still an
important measure
um for for certain reason as you as you
mentioned but nevertheless the key is a
key
um measure that we always tend to look
at is a CPA because that is what the
bank of England uses to Target its
monetary policy
now Sterling has risen against both the
US dollar and the Euro this morning I
mean the market appears to be pricing in
another interest rate rise next month
would you go along with that yeah I
think it is almost a done deal now given
what we've seen both with today's
daytime yesterday data was relatively
strong
um wage growth
presumably uh the bank will be most
worried about core inflation which was
unchanged during the month at 6.2
percent
yeah I mean core inflation has been
relatively strong and persistently
strong and it is not going down as fast
as we would have hoped and therefore it
is understandable that the bank of
England is worried
um about the inflationary pressures
because you really need that core
inflation to start moderating we're
already seeing the energy prices going
down so that is impacting headline
inflation but it's a core that needs to
go down as well
now clearly inflation is proving
stickier in other uh economies as well I
mean it's uh higher than expected in the
US right now is this making you rethink
at all about the global direction of
interest rates I mean Equity markets
certainly uh have been under a cloud
this week from the prospect of another
rate racer in the Fed
yeah I mean central banks generally are
in a tricky position at the moment
because we've seen some pressure
um through the turmoil in in the banking
sector and and some of the incidents we
had earlier on that makes makes you
think that such a quick increase in
interest rates can have an impact that
is very much undesired in terms of the
stability of the banking system or all
other things that can crop out so
they've already increased interest rates
quite aggressively from the low level
where they were but in not in real terms
rates are still relatively low when you
look at you comparing nominal interest
rates and inflation and inflation is not
going down as quickly as a home so
it is a difficult position to be in
yes as you say headline CPI coming down
much more slowly than either the office
of budget responsibility or the bank of
England itself was expecting where do
you see the uh trajectory of inflation
over coming months
well ultimately we are expecting
inflation headline inflation to go down
significantly this year across
um the range of economies that have had
that shock
um particularly driven by the rising
Energy prices because the energy prices
are lower and because they come out of
this base effect from that big increase
that we saw last year so that is likely
to happen maybe more slowly but it is
still likely to happen and then what we
could see is that as as inflation is
moderating much more that can be start
to be embedded much more in inflation
expectations and also in people's
behavior in their demand for wages wage
Rises and as well in the way companies
um price their product so that could be
in a way self-fulfilling as well and
this is what we're hoping that there
actually won't be that much of a need to
increase the interest rate so much given
that as inflation is going to go down
that will change behaviors and that
would save central banks from being far
too aggressive at a point where we could
still see more impact from that big
increase in rates
all right yeah I've got to leave it
there good to see you this morning thank
you
well now Central bankers and politicians
love to say that their decision making
is as the saying goes led by the data
for there's growing evidence that
Executives and managers are being
overwhelmed by too much data more than a
quarter of Business Leaders admit that
they rely on gut feeling more these days
than after being overloaded with data
during the last three years well that
was the finding of a global report
published today by the technology
company Oracle who's senior vice
president Siobhan Wilson joins the
national welcome to you is this all data
data overload oh completely absolutely
it's um you know the the study has shown
us that there's so much data now that
Business Leaders you know looking at
this data and just it's completely
overwhelming and really finding it hard
to make decisions and yet according to
your findings British managers are far
more likely to sort of regret decisions
that they've made than their peers in
France and Germany are they just not as
good as interpreting this data and
dealing with it I don't think it's that
they're not as good I think it's really
just about the amount of data and
looking at that data and not being able
to make decisions around the data so I
think the universally it's the same
problem everywhere I think maybe
culturally the UK a little bit more
cautious than other people maybe but
yeah generally it's a universal issue
that we're seeing so why are we
struggling with this data explosion I
think because you know even in our
personal lives if you think about it and
in our business lives that there's so
much data and we need to make much more
decisions now you know the decisions we
have to make are multiplying ten times
over and the and the data that we're
getting is so much it's so overwhelming
it's becoming too hard to understand so
I think that's why people are struggling
with it and really struggling to make
decisions with it will that improve with
experience people will learn how to sort
of sort the wheat from the chaff as it
were well I think it's more around you
know what when is the right data and
where where do you get the right data
and I think that's what people are
struggling with there's so much data now
you don't need every bit of data that's
available to you you just need the right
data at the right time to be able to
make those decisions and we've looked at
you know a lot of research told us in
that that over 70 percent of people
wanted technology and robots to make
those decisions for them and I think
that's what you know that's what we're
trying to look at they need the right
data so the technology to give them the
right data rather than getting all this
data in front of them and going what do
I do with that you know because it's
just so much that's very interesting I
mean we've been talking an awful lot on
this program lately about artificial
intelligence I mean this sounds like
from what you're saying something where
AI may come to the rescue yeah I think
so but it again it's about the right AI
embedded in the right areas rather than
because again AI can come from all areas
but it's about using the right
analytical analytics within the AI
embedded in those applications to give
you the right data at the right time and
that will make you help you give you the
right decisions so who does that is it a
software vendor like or is it the
businesses themselves on the other end
of all this there is software it's
technology so there is there is lots of
analytical software out there Oracle
Cloud technologies have have lots of
Technology available to help
organizations build their build their AI
beneath it but yes it's all around the
technologies that available to them and
can that be made available to a client
on a bespoke basis so that it can
address their very individual needs yeah
absolutely it's really about the
customer needs you know we're always
looking at what is the customer
challenges and how can we help those
customers the challenges that they've
got and Technology can always help it's
just about finding that right technology
that can help them and it's just
understanding the customer what they
want at that point in time
it's actually quite depressing having
this conversation it kind of makes me
think that a lot of Executives a lot of
managers they're basically going to be
dummies on a machine now really doing
what uh they're told no they still need
to make the decisions it's just about
making them making giving them the right
data behind those decisions rather than
having to do it from gut feeling all the
time because sometimes you find you know
some of our surveys said that they felt
that the leaders were making gut
decisions rather than what they're
they've got from the data and actually
they wouldn't need to do that if they
had the right data because then the the
day they're not trusting the data at the
moment because there's too much and I
think we need to get back to Business
Leaders trusting the data that they're
being given why do you think they don't
why why do you think that they just go
with the gut it can't just be down to
date or overload surely I think it is
but combination of the amount of
decisions that they've got to make
combined with the amount of data that
they've got it's just become completely
overwhelming and we need to be able to
get those Business Leaders trusting the
data that we're giving them so that they
can make quick and fast decisions you
know
companies are in a massive change at the
moment but they always are really but at
the moment with the economical pressures
competition they've got to be moving
fast they've got to be agile they've got
to be resilient and all of that data
will help them make those decisions to
be able to do those things you don't
think it's because the data is telling
them things that they don't want to hear
potentially but no I think it's really
about just making sure they've got that
right data and you know trusting that
data and I think that's where because of
the overwhelming volume of it they're
less trustful of it at the moment and we
can help them make sure that they can
get that trust back all right it's good
to see you this morning thank you very
much thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and Heineken has reported a bigger
than expected drop in beer sales for the
first three months of the year the
world's second largest Brewer said that
beer volumes During the period were down
three percent on the same months last
year due to Temporary weaknesses in its
key markets of Vietnam and Nigeria but
the Dutch company which was also hit by
its decision to stop selling in Russia
following the invasion of Ukraine said
trading have been strong in Brazil the
United States the UK Spain and the
Netherlands
the commodity and trading and Mining
giant glencore said this morning it
would be prepared to raise its offer for
the Canadian minor Tech resources the
ftse 100 company has so far been
rebuffed by Tech despite offering 22 and
a half billion dollars to date while its
chief executive Gary Nagel traveled to
Canada last month to meet you a week to
meet shareholders Tech is in the process
of spinning off its metallurgical coal
business and focusing on its copper and
zinc assets
and line trust one of the UK's best
known fund managers said this morning
that profits for the year would be
better than expected the company said it
now expects profits for the year to be
at least 86 million pounds driven
primarily by stronger than expected
performance for you revenues John Irons
the chief executive held the acquisition
of rival majidi Asset Management last
year not only for generating 12 million
pounds in performance fees during the
year but also for broadening the group's
investment capability
and the sac CBI director General Tony
danker has attacked the lobby groups
decision to fire him saying his
reputation has been totally destroyed
when they fired me
they told me that some of the things
I've done and they named them
these were things that just a week or
two earlier they said didn't Merit any
disciplinary action
and now they told me they merited
immediate dismissal
and look you know I've been around the
block and I know the way the world works
but it's so clear
I've been made the full guy
not that they just threw me under the
bus they reversed the bus back over me
Asda has launched what it claims is the
UK's biggest trial to date of autonomous
grocery home shopping delivery it's
partnering with wave the uk-based
autonomous Vehicle Group in a 12-month
trial to deliver grocery orders using
self-driving vehicles to customers of
asda's Park Royal Superstore in
Northwest London which you want to be
now is Alex Kendall he's chief executive
of waiver Alex welcome to you I mean the
groceries are going to be transported
from the store to the home in a
self-driving vehicle but there will
still be people on board
that's right this is a trial uh so we're
using it to develop our technology and
really understand what it takes to
deploy autonomous driving at scale we're
going to have a safety operator on board
who's going to be monitoring the system
for two reasons uh firstly because we're
establishing and developing the levels
of safety required to launch
autonomously and secondly because
legislation is not yet here which
enables us to operate autonomous
vehicles in the UK yeah so what do you
hope to establish from this trial well
it's the first of its kind I mean to to
give you some context autonomous driving
trials today have really been
constrained to quite small geofenced or
constrained areas in cities uh like ones
in in desert areas like Arizona where
the sun always shines and you've got
white boulevards we spent the last five
years developing artificial intelligence
technology that lets us operate in
really Dynamic and complex environments
like we're doing here in London
um so it's a new possibility for the
industry and the routes I gather are
going to be determined by AI
also the beauty is that we're not
changing the routes that uh you know
Asda sees today and their operations
we're able to operate on the routes they
expect and do so because our system is
learning to drive based on what it sees
so it doesn't rely on preset routes or
things like this but the catchment area
is enormous with this this trial it's
over 170 000 residents in North West
London and that's because of the the
level of intelligence we've got on board
the system that lets it navigate that
diverse set of customers and does this
have the potential to be rolled out to
other Asda stores in due course we hope
that's what we aim to establish in this
trial we've been developing this
technology for about five years and
we've tested in over 10 UK cities
ourselves but this is the very first
commercial deployment so it's a hugely
exciting moment for ourselves and our
partners yeah I like the fact that you
say that London's roads are a little
more different from Los Angeles should
we say I mean to that end you just took
I mean Microsoft we should say it's one
of your backers you just took Bill Gates
out for a spin in London ah that was a
it was a wonderful ride we picked him up
from his hotel in central London and he
chose a route to a fish and chip shop in
North London and so we drove on this
we've never done that route before but
we were able to navigate autonomously
past the cyclists and pedestrians and
Central Soho and do so in a way that it
was a very human-like Driving Experience
where the vehicle wasn't rigid and
stopped starting but it could naturally
drive and coexist in the in the other
traffic in that in that area and Bill
Gates was was he happy at the end of it
it was uh it was well he's still in one
piece clearly I think he was chuffed
now I mean Microsoft are one of a number
of Big Blue Chip backers that you have
do you have the capital that you require
right now to do everything that you're
trying to do in terms of development and
testing
well to put it in perspective and it's
an extraordinary
um difficult problem to solve one of the
the biggest in in the world right now uh
to to get autonomy out there at scale
and to get artificial intelligence in
the real world we've raised 260 million
dollars to date and that's given us the
Firepower to go and build and deploy
this this first commercial trial of
course we need to raise more Capital to
to bring this to Market
um but the opportunity is extraordinary
it's it's you know it's a trillion
dollar market for a reason and it's
going to completely change the way we
move people on Goods around cities and
tell me about the vehicles that you're
using in this draw so the vehicles we're
starting with our first generation
vehicle which is on a Jaguar i-pace
vehicle but one of the neat things that
we've demonstrated with our technology
is that it can adapt to new and
different types of vehicles and so we're
looking to expand in our second
generation vehicle uh we'll be moving to
like commercial Vans like the ones that
you see typically operated in grocery
today very good Alex good to see you
this morning
now ministers are warning today that the
UK is facing what they call
ideologically motivated cyber attacks
from Russian aligned groups but cyber
attacks are now being detected more
quickly than ever while product
providers of cyber security services and
other external sources are notifying
organizations of compromises more often
than internal security teams are finding
them well those are just two of the
findings of the M Trends 2023 report
published by mandian consulting which is
part of Google Cloud joining me now is
the head of manly Consulting for Europe
the Middle East and Africa Stuart
Mackenzie uh Stuart welcome to you this
all sounds pretty encouraging
uh yes I think we are seeing significant
improvements in organizations
organizations are definitely getting
better we saw Global Mean Time detection
so this the dwell time is the thing that
we measure it measures the amount of
time an attacker is in a network before
they're detected we use a median rather
than an average because with cyber
attacks there's quite often you know
extensive outliers maybe someone's
detected and one day maybe someone's
detected four years later and that skews
the number so using a medium dwell time
detection gives you a really good
understanding of you know the average
time that organizations are beginning to
detect attackers in environments
globally that dropped from 21 days in
2021 down to 16 days in 2022 in a mere
the picture is slightly different we saw
it drop from 48 days down to 20. so
we're beginning to detect uh attackers
in environments within 20 days that's
within three weeks within um within um
notification events
now on the downside Russia's attacks on
Ukraine appear to be getting more
sophisticated this is what Oliver Dowden
is going to be speaking about in Belfast
later today how can the West counter
that
well I think it's about having a
holistic approach to cyber security I
think it's important for organizations
not to overly index or overly switch to
worrying about purely Russia it's
important to think about the whole
security posture the organization holds
and the threat it faces trying to think
about the threat that would be faced
from Russia and the targeting we see in
Ukraine where we've been supporting
Ukraine since the start of the conflict
that's a very different type of conflict
than we'd see an organizational face
from ransomware
um there's not going to be many
organizations that will be targeted I
think Oliver's talking about critical
National infrastructure and I think it's
really important we see critical
National infrastructure improve and
critical National infrastructure is a
multi-stakeholder environment it's not a
single organization that's responsible
for a lot of those environments so it's
about pushing security down through the
whole supply chain it's about looking at
your security posture and your supplier
security posture rather than just
thinking we put in some technology and
we're quite life now
one of the other lines in the report
that uh struck me you mentioned the
risks posed by a group called apt-42
what can you tell me about them yeah
it's the irgc the Islamic revolutionary
guard
um they are very focused on threats to
the nation
um and are very focused on both external
and internal threats it's interesting to
see how they've how they've changed over
we've been tracking them since 2015 and
they've significantly changed when we
change a group to be an apt it's because
we understand their profiling their
targeting and what they're aiming to do
they've grown over time it's um it's a
capability though that I think every
nation now aspires to have either
organizations have a strong cyber
capability although one to a massive
strong cyber capability I think it's a
default position I think Lindy Cameron
yesterday spoke about how important it
is that you know we we make sure we keep
pace for cyber security because if
anyone takes a significant leave she
called out China I think if anyone takes
a significant lead in that it will be
very hard to play catch up I think it's
important that we look at every single
nation state and try and make sure that
we have capabilities to defend against
that some of that's got to come from
ncsc
um because they are going to set that
agenda they're going to see more but
lots of organizations can understand
what they're doing and test their own
environments it's important to test with
decent red team capabilities to test
your environment against a threat you're
likely to see rather than just
take an intelligence feed from ncsc and
understand their policy you need to
actively test your environment on an
ongoing basis to understand if you have
a capability to defend against attacks
and do we have the sufficient talent in
this country Stuart to be able to equip
ncsc and uh gchq with the people they
need
yes I think we do I think we
build Workforce we have intelligent
coming through but I do think some of
that comes down to encouraging more
girls into stem I think we have to get a
more diverse population coming into
cyber security rather than just a bunch
of you know old fat white men like
myself we need to get different ways of
thinking and education so we can bring
through more cyber Talent into the
future I think we have the capability we
just have to encourage it all right well
from one old fat white man to another
Stuart good to talk to you this morning
thank you thank you
still to come here onion King live we'll
have a look at how Global markets are
doing this Wednesday morning don't go
away
[Music]
foreign
Mark Stone and I'm Sky's correspondent
based here in Washington DC
well the plan seems to be to head to the
police station where the policeman who
fired the shots was based
thing you know is never
I've witnessed a remarkable passion for
politics here but the anger too we have
to get Trump out of the White House on
Playing devil's advocate you get your
political agenda no it's honest God love
you and Beyond the United States I
report from around the world
a town that is effectively encircled by
the Russians
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our planet
quite a few explosions uh in the
distance here in Jerusalem
what do you think of Isis everybody here
they know the truth of Isis
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back now while many of us are
feeling the pinch the luxury yacht
Market is booming with global sales
expected to grow from 9.38 billion
dollars this year to 13.6 billion
dollars by the end of the decade well if
you're contemplating buying a new vessel
or simply want to admire them the place
to be this week is London luxury of
floats a boutique style show being
hosted at St Catherine docks near Tower
Bridge where the event is being put on
by British Marine the trade Association
for the UK Leisure super yacht and small
commercial marine industry it's chief
executive Leslie Robinson joins me now
Leslie welcome to you this is the second
year you've run this event I presume
last last year must have been a roaring
success then
last year was a great success and this
is day two now of our five day show last
year was four days four days but this is
an extra day going through to Saturday
night
how much business got done last year
a great deal otherwise our exhibitors
wouldn't be back we've got fantastic
luxury shop Yachts on show Sun Seekers
princesses etc etc beautiful oysters and
we're encouraging everybody to come down
to this beautiful location it's London's
Central Marina um and it's a fantastic
showcase as you say Boutique for these
wonderful luxury yachts and where is
demand strongest right now
it strung across the board still
um you quoted some figures our figures
say that uh our revenues for the legend
Marine industry grew about 25 last year
through to June 22 and if you look at
that that's about 6.5 ahead of the
pandemic levels so as sales are strong
clearly there is a cost of living impact
on um margins and so forth at the moment
but the industry is still pretty boy
which is fantastic for UK PLC and
particularly for jobs in the whole
supply chain Leslie what do you put this
buoyancy of demand down to is it uh
people replacing uh existing vessels and
put all perhaps trading up or are these
new customers
I think it's a combination of both we
are certainly seeing some new customers
uh and I think that is pandemic effect
and that's fantastic
um people as you know have got savings
and that's why we're encouraging
visitors to come down here to St
Catherine's dog we've got four more days
to go tickets are still available London
London luxuryafloat.com and we really
would encourage people to come down and
have a look for themselves I mean the UK
is a major player in this market you
mentioned some of the individual
businesses the likes of oyster Sun
seeker and Princess where does this
expertise and and Market strength come
from
we have a long tradition of boat
building in the UK everything through
from design to manufacture to supply
chain
um it's a it's our Hidden Gem I think
and what we want to do is make a real
Splash about it hence showcase it it's
casing it in central London as well as
the the national Southampton um
International Boat Show which of course
happens every September
now princess which is based in Plymouth
employs nearly three and a half thousand
people down there it's just change hands
it's been sold from one U.S private
Equity Firm to another does it matter
that these businesses are not
necessarily British owned
I don't think so when you have the right
backer who understands UK PLC and
British industry I think the the
um importance is the longevity of the
investment and the production facilities
because of course that's all about jobs
and further production which boosts
growth now a lot of luxury Yachts that
were previously owned by sanctioned
Russians have been seized by governments
around the world what's happening to
those assets
um I can't really comment on that we
have very little from our statistics
there's very little in Russian hands um
export wise we export roughly about 30
across the board in the leisure marine
industry a tiny tiny proportion has gone
to Russia I'm not aware of any issues
that we've seen whatsoever I mean when I
was driving up though was that
potentially if these governments decide
to sell these vessels onto the open
market it might depress uh depress uh
business somewhat
it could but I think that's a very small
proportion compared to um the general
amount of export we've most of our
manufacturers or in fact all of our
manufacturers still have a long waiting
list in terms of customers ready to buy
boats right typically how long would a
waiting list be
at the moment it's been up to two years
and at the moment I'm still hearing 18
months to two years in terms of some of
these wonderful uh big Yachts crikey I
mean a tastes changing over time in
terms of the kind of size of the boat
that people are going for these days
yeah we are definitely seeing some
Trends uh certainly a trend for for
bigger boats big boats that are easier
if it's self-crewed easier to to crew
and so forth yes there are some changes
going on at the moment
all right Leslie we've got to leave it
there great to see you this morning I'm
glad to see there's a bit of wind down
at uh St Catherine's dock as well
there is indeed thank you very much
indeed take care
now as we were discussing earlier the
chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster all
of a daraden is speaking to cyber
security conference in Belfast about the
threat to the UK of Russian cyber
attacks we're just going to listen in
briefly
these are the types of tools that we
used to only see in a handful of State
actors and which can cause serious
damage
so it's something we're taking very
seriously and to which we are responding
with our International partners
meanwhile cyber crime is estimated to
cost the UK billions of pounds each year
according to new figures published today
32 of UK businesses and Charities
suffered a cyber breach or attack in the
past year that is a third of our
businesses
and ransomware continues to run rampant
and as prime minister as President Biden
rightly recognized a few weeks ago
thanks to its scale and its impact
ransomware is no longer just a crime
it's a national security threat
and our response needs to reflect the
severity of that threat
these are attacks on our citizens
our businesses and our democracy
they are an attempt to undermine our
society and we are determined to stop
them with your help
in the UK we grasp the need for Urgent
action early and we've been doing a lot
over the past few years to strengthen
our cyber defenses
we have published the national cyber
strategy and we have a new and effective
cyber sanctions regime which we recently
used for the first time against a group
of Russian cyber criminals as part of a
joint campaign with the United States
and we're working closely with
International Partners to tackle the
proliferation of sophisticated
commercial cyber tools
at the same time the government itself
continues to face a range of attacks
including ransomware and Espionage and
so we are constantly looking to
strengthen our cyber defenses
and as part of that today I can announce
that we are launching gov ashore a
transformational new Cyber regime for
the whole of government Governor Shaw
will be rolled out across Whitehall it
will be used to assess every
Department's cyber Health on an annual
basis against stringent new measures so
that government can better identify the
risks we face and make sure we are
protecting systems that help us run
Public Services
so with each day as the threat evolves
so does our response
but a new adversary has emerged
over the last 18 months the national
cyber security Center has seen the rise
of several Russian aligned groups
sympathetic to Putin's invasion of
Ukraine
now these are Fringe State threats the
Cyber equivalent of the Wagner group and
initially those groups focus their
attacks on Ukraine and the surrounding
region
but recently they have begun to turn
their attention to the United Kingdom
and its allies
they are now seeking opportunities to
compromise our critical National
infrastructure
we have experienced attempted attacks in
the past
but these groups operate differently
instead of seeking to profit or spy on
us
their primary motive is to disrupt or
destroy our infrastructure
these adversaries are ideologically
motivated rather than financially
motivated
secondly
through these perpetrators though these
perpetrators are aligned to National
actors crucially they're often not
controlled by those foreign States
that makes them more opportunistic and
less likely to show restraint
together those factors make the current
situation particularly concerning
and so today I can confirm that the
national cyber security Center is
issuing an official alert to operators
of our critical National infrastructure
to highlight the risk they currently
face
that alert is now live on the ncsc's
website along with a number of
recommended actions that operators
should follow right now to increase
their resilience and help defend our
infrastructure against these attacks
this threat is not something we do
likely
this is an unprecedented warning for
business we've never publicly
highlighted the threat from these kinds
of groups attempting such attacks before
and I should stress that we do not think
that they currently have the capability
to cause widespread damage to our
infrastructure in the United Kingdom
but we do believe it is necessary at
this point of time if we want companies
to understand the threat they currently
face
and to take action to defend themselves
and the country against such attacks
this approach fits with that wider
National Security strategy
and last year
when we saw that Russian forces were
gathering at the Ukrainian border we
Declassified the information to let the
world see what they were doing
today with cyber threats you will
increasingly see us say what we are
seeing we won't allow these groups to
stay in the shadows
we're shining a light on these threats
because we need to work together to
strengthen our defenses
that means that businesses need to see
the threats clearly too
and over the last few years we've done
lots of things to make it easier for
businesses to secure themselves
so there we go that was Oliver Dowden
who's the chancellor of the duchy of
Lancaster he is also of course the
National Security and investment
Minister saying that in the last few
minutes the UK facing unprecedented
threats from Russian aligned entities a
clearly very significant intervention
there from the minister we will have
more reaction to that throughout the
morning here on Sky News
[Music]
well the pound has risen against both
the US dollar and the Euro on those
higher than expected inflation numbers
uh it's given back a few of those gains
now Sterling was ahead by quarter one
percent against dollar earlier on this
morning still up a tenth of one percent
right now as you can see The single
currency has clawed its way uh back uh
against uh Sterling uh the Euro pound
actually ahead by some quarter one
percent right now against the Euro The
single currency meanwhile off a third of
one percent right now against the dollar
on the equity markets it was a largely
downbeat session overnight in the Asia
Pacific region the Nikka in Tokyo
suffered its first reverse in nine
sessions uh Sydney more or less the only
uh index in the region not to finish in
negative territory well in Europe pretty
similar story uh let's show you the
Continental European indices only the
Ibex in Madrid in positive territory
right now we were expecting some
Eurozone inflation data anytime now that
may have had a bearing on things talking
points in Europe this morning include
asml we were talking about this so
yesterday with guy Ellison from investec
the concentration of some big
heavyweight stocks in various indices
around the world and asml we are Dutch
chips giant is certainly one of them
very very big constituent in the Dutch
stock index the shares they're currently
off two and a quarter percent that's
despite uh strong growth in quarterly
profits investors uh homing in instead
on the more cautious Outlook statement
well here in London the ftse 100 is in
negative territory as well currently uh
off nearly two-fifths of one percent
it's a broad base sell-off among leading
Blue Chip fallers this morning is Anto
fagasta the Chilean copper Miner it's
got a production report out this morning
shares off some three percent right now
other than that there are not an awful
lot of individual features in the ftse
for investors to hang their hats on this
morning although there's a fair bit more
going on outside the uh ftse all the big
dollar and Euro earners I should say are
weaker on the stronger pound outside the
ftse the software company kanos is down
by some five percent that's following a
trading update but the commercial
vehicle rental provider red and
Northgate is ahead by nearly eight
percent on news that full year profits
are going to be better than expected
meanwhile the aura Field Services Group
hunting is up some three percent right
now two and three quarter percent right
now in fact on a trading update as for
the oil price well that's sold off again
uh this morning amid mounting
expectations of another rate rise from
the US Federal Reserve and that sell-off
has picked up a bit of pace in the last
half our Battle of Brent crude currently
changing hands at 82.97 a barrel that is
off a little over two percent so joining
me this morning is the head of
interactive investors head of investment
as an interactive investor Victoria
scholar Victoria good to see you um
interesting results last night from
Netflix they were a bit of a mixed bag
weren't they really yeah that's right we
saw a big move to the downside after
hours but it managed to recoup those
initial losses uh they were broadly in
line in terms of the earnings and the
revenue number but that closely watched
subscriber number fell short of
expectations 1.75 million was the number
and of course we know that market
participants are always eyeing that
number very very closely I think another
interesting bit was this big cut in its
content budget it's planning to spend a
billion less dollars and we know that
content is King and it's an extremely
competitive sector and we know that
social media and
streaming followers are very fickle they
jump from platform to platform and any
platform is only really as good as its
latest piece of content so whether that
works out is yet to be seen yeah quite
so now this morning we've heard from
Heineken mentioned them over in the
program I mean beer volume Sudan but the
share price is up this morning yeah
again a bit of a mixed picture we saw a
beat on the revenue line profit was down
year on year and then bear volumes fell
certain geographies suffered like um
Nigeria and Vietnam but then there were
some bright spots as well like China
which saw big growth in terms of beer we
know that beer is quite resilient to an
economic downturn it tends to hold up so
although we have seen this like decline
I think there is still a reason to be
optimistic towards this stock and it has
done pretty well so far this year now I
mentioned other trading Updates this
morning National Express caught your eye
yeah that's right you know it's a bit of
a mixed picture it's had a tough time so
far this year it's down by about 10 uh
the UK coach business has done well
because of the rail strikes but then
there's the UK bus strikes to contend
with national rails saying that uh The
Best Is Yet To Come in terms of its U.S
bus season and also the coach season in
Spain and the UK so although it's had a
bit of a tough time so far it could pick
up later this year all right Victoria
couldn't leave it there good to see you
this morning thank you
thank you
timeline for a look at this morning's
business pages and the financial times
leads its print edition with yesterday's
quarterly results from Goldman Sachs
during which the Wall Street banking
giant announced it had suffered an 18
drop in quarterly profits that followed
a disappointing performance in fixed
income currencies and commodities
trading meanwhile on its Digital
Editions right now the Ft currently
leading with the inflation figures
that's one might expect the hot story of
the morning the times leads its business
pages with an attack by the leading
shareholder in HSBC on the bank's bosses
pringham the Chinese insurer that owns
an eight percent stake in HSBC wants the
lender to spin off its Asian Division
and accuse management of being
close-minded about the idea of a breakup
the times also reports that lawyers for
Jess Staley have been given the chance
to question the former Barclays Chief
Executives ex-boss at JP Morgan over
allegations surrounding the crimes of
Jeffrey Epstein who of course was a
client of jestel is when he was at JP
Morgan
meanwhile The Daily Telegraph leads with
last night's Court settlement between
U.S media giant Fox and Dominion voting
systems to settle claims by Fox News at
the latter's products were used to rig
the 2020 U.S presidential election in
favor of Joe Biden the paper also
reports we've been running this story
this morning on the channel as well at
sales of cassettes have hit a two decade
High that's a number of musicians feel
demand for the Retro format joining me
today is the sun's business editor
Ashley Armstrong Ashley good to see
we'll start with the telegraph because
there's a story that caught your eye
there yes no yeah morning
um I think it's really interesting so
the government is saying that it's going
to scrap its Business Council which is
meant to be you know the Great and the
good of business and uh meant to Foster
environments and so you know essentially
number 10 can hear right from the
Beating Heart of of a business but how
effective that Business Council remains
to be seen I mean arguably I was getting
texts this morning not very at all and
not representative of small business in
particular and actually last at the
start of the year I did a story about
this business Council and the majority
of these companies that were meant to be
kind of you know put on the pedestal of
this is how we should be doing business
they hadn't actually signed up to the
government's prompt payment code 12 of
them only seven had and these are meant
to be kind of like the standards of
paying suppliers on time which as we
know is like the biggest cash Crunch and
when I was writing the story it took me
three government departments I was being
ping-ponged as we all are aware of how
that feels in government between
businesses just to even find out if this
Council still existed so I don't think
it was the number one priority for
government no it's not raising the dead
some of these uh why all press
departments at times isn't it I mean
it's very interesting though I mean we
keep hearing that I mean there's a story
this morning that says Richie sunac is
going to try and press the reset button
on relations with business yeah I mean
it feels to me like he is the first
Prime Minister in a long time to
actually care about business I mean
Boris Johnson clearly yeah
becoming uh Theresa May likewise was
pretty lugum it feels like Richie soon
Acts trying to be a bit more engaged
well yeah I mean and Theresa May element
that was very much you know the
unacceptable face of capitalism it was
that era and then yeah Boris kind of
really put that down on the pegging seat
and it is interesting you know kind of
how he's wanting to reset mainly because
also he's aware labor have been doing
some really good inroads
um meeting movers and shakers and I
think people find that impressive but
what I'm sure you're hearing as well is
that you know business like the
stability and in fact I wrote this week
you know what business really needs as
we all know is confidence and certainty
and I think Rishi has now been in the
job for quadruples a length that Liz
Tross had
um so in this new world that's been seen
as you know a sign of confidence and
stability and maybe he'll be around for
a few more months to kind of actually
set something that resembles slightly a
long-term plan yeah you never know I
mean elsewhere it's been quite a busy
week for for corporate deals haven't
there three three mid caps have received
takeover approaches is Doom making back
it's a frison of excitement on Monday
wasn't it yeah I I mean I I love
covering deals and I think last year
there had been virtually none at all and
so deal making is back but from kind of
an incredibly low base I mean we're
talking like down 1990s historic levels
um and you know we all know why dealers
have been uh delayed political
instability suddenly interest rates
making private Equity debt a lot more
expensive and borrowing costs foreign
costs soaring but now they kind of see
where interest rates are going so I
think you're going to see a lot more
overseas acquirers and private Equity
deals keep us during this busy won't it
yeah exactly actually good to see thank
you
still to come here on Ian King live the
world's first company to deploy an
autonomous electric vehicle on a public
road launches in the UK don't go away
[Music]
I'm Mark Stone and I'm Sky's
correspondent based here in Washington
DC
well the plan seems to be to head to the
police station where the policeman who
fired the shots was based
[Music]
thing you know is man
his memory I've witnessed a remarkable
passion for politics here but the anger
too we have to get Trump out of the
White House on Playing devil's advocate
you get your political agenda no it's
honestly God love you and Beyond the
United States I report from around the
world
the town that is effectively encircled
by the Russians
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our planet
in the distance here in Jerusalem
what do you think of Isis everybody here
they know the truth of Isis
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now earlier in the program
we spoke to the autonomous Vehicle Group
wave and now to continue the theme we
have an autonomous truck maker einright
founded in Stockholm in 2016 was the
world's first company to deploy an
autonomous electric vehicle on a public
road it's launched in a number of
countries already including Germany
Belgium the Netherlands and Luxembourg
and today marks its launch here in the
United Kingdom will joining me now is
the chief executive and co-founder of
einroyd Robert Falk Robert good to see
you this morning
informed your opening schedule and
launch schedule
I mean we are launching here in the UK
because we think this is a natural next
step for us I mean the UK has always
been the Forefront of Transport I mean
that's the whole wealth of the nation
has been built on it I mean you've been
pioneering the channels you've been
pioneering the steam engines the
railroad not the new technology that has
been the world for this nation I'm glad
to see you and be a part of being in
this next step an autonomous and
electric is the next step now you've
when you've launched in other countries
for example Germany you did so in
partnership with businesses like
Electrolux and I gather you're doing
that here as well correct we are glad to
do that now the collaboration PepsiCo
and Walkers so we can glad to say that
we are actually partnering with it talk
with the real Walkers not the talkers so
what sort of uh how is that
collaboration going to manifest itself
this is going to mean that we're
actually going to start to ship electric
I mean 20 of the CO2 emissions from the
UK is from heavy weighted transport and
with these kind of solutions we can
address that so we're going to start to
see now electric lorries or trucks on
the road actually shipping ships in this
case and when will that start let's
start already in June this year right
right very exciting yeah yeah and uh and
where are the trucks manufactured when
Enron is not a truck manufacturer we
have been since the start we have a
service provider so what we are doing
together with the clients like PepsiCo
is to provide them better service but
for instance with digital electric and
autonomous Transport service so we work
with multiple Hardware manufacturers to
bring this technology to the market
art tour offering is to be the
technology provider and the solution
provider enabling the business case of
going electric and you're agnostic about
which truck makers you work with then we
work with them the ones that has the
best quality and where we can integrate
our technology platform into and where
we can bring the latest and greatest to
the market and what will success look
like with with this launch
for us it's about scaling we have been
in the of live operations since 2019 in
Sweden and for now we're scaling it up
to four for fifth upscale with a lot of
our clients so we see that roughly 30 to
40 percent of the heavy duty Freight
transport could be electrified now with
a business case with their Hardware
costs coming down over the next five
years it could be up to 50 to 60 that
should go electric driven on the
business case itself and what sort of
things did you have to say to PepsiCo
and Walkers to to get them on board what
were they looking for from you
High precision transport sustainable at
the cost of a competitive price
and you can't disclose the price of
course I assume well it's going to cost
you extra
it's okay I mean you've just completed
in the last uh nine months I think of
funding round and under debt raising it
gives you access to about 500 million
dollars worth of capital right now what
will that enable you to do presumably
that's not all going on the UK launch
presumably there are other markets
you're targeting as well yeah half of
that is going to be just a large event
itself no it's suppose we'll go for uh
scaling together with clients we have a
huge amount we are looking at 50 to
60-bit clients Global kinds that are now
taking their goals with going CO2
literal very serious so they are willing
to depict the risk you're going with
young players like ours and try what we
can they can really do about the supply
chain are you happy with the mix of debt
inequity
I mean we were very fortunate to have
the partnership with Barclays and the
depth goes directly into scaling and
deploying and for instance the trucks
that we will utilize for the transport
service here and will come from Barclays
so that's the way to finance the whole
rollout so I think that Barclays is
really helping us to make the future
happen so we're very fortunate to have
great investors and great depth
providers all right Robert it's good to
talk to you this morning hopefully I'll
see you again in future thanks for
joining me thank you